patrick sébastien vous allait essuyer
les plâtres d'une nouvelle interview ça
m'intéresse qu'ils s'appellent
l'interview fromage ou dessert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes plutôt fromage ou
dessert fromage vous êtes amour du matin
ou amour du soir alors c'est du matin
mais c'est du soir pour moi est ce que
je me couche à 6 heures du matin dakar
vous êtes sharon mme arafat
tu vas pas que tu parles d'un mur les
strings aux culottes strings
ouais c'est le truc où il faut est ce
que disait bigard un avant fallait
écarter la culotte pour dans les faits
ce n'est en fait qu'un téléphone je
salue vous êtes elie et dieudonné
dieudonné parce que parce qu'il a été
d'une violence extrême avec moi ouais
qu'il a été d'une méchanceté voulais me
finir au lance flammes mais c'est qu'il
a été méchant avec tout le monde qu'il a
fait beaucoup d'erreurs mais qu'on ne
peut pas être comme ça sans avoir au
fond une vraie révolte et être au fond
profondément sincère c'est beau le
pardon vous êtes fossiles faussent
lèvres plutôt fausse lèvres pour des
questions de confort
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes noël au balcon ou paco rabanne
i'm a amusé paco rabanne
c'est un fou furieux vous êtes par
devant par derrière plutôt par derrière
vous êtes herbe ou chiites ni l'un ni
l'autre
non c'est pas du tout mon truc alors je
vais te dire pour plusieurs raisons je
n'ai pas de jouer les violets ou
d'avancement engueuler parce que c'est
ça le nouveau gros maire de metz moselle
a fait deux soldats initiaux à dire non
non moi je trouve ça ringard pétards
j'aime pas l'odeur c'est le conte
l'odeur me dérange quelque chose qui me
dérange donc un enjeu maintenant qu'elle
est un problème
moi je vais bien je veux bien qu'on
fasse l'apologie de ça mais je n'en veux
pas la pole je veux qu'on fasse souffler
les mecs dans les bagnoles aussi mais
aussi dans les mecs qui ont picoler vous
êtes café de flore ou deux magots ça
c'est des cafés où je vais pas du tout
non je suis plutôt la bodega carcassonne
dormeurs
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus